Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Approximately a year ago, we talked about
an absolutely amazing paper by the name vid2game,
in which we could grab a controller and become
video game characters.
It was among the first, introductory papers
to tackle this problem, and in this series,
we always say that two more papers down the
line, and it will be improved significantly,
so let’s see what’s in store, and this
time, just one more paper down the line.
This new work offers an impressive value proposition,
which is to transform a real tennis match
into a realistic looking video game that is
controllable.
This includes synthesizing not only movements,
but also what effect the movements have on
the ball as well.
So, how do we control this?
And now, hold on to your papers, because we
can specify where the next shot would land
with just one click.
For instance, we can place this red dot here.
And now, just think about the fact that this
doesn’t just change where the ball should
go, but the trajectory of the ball should
be computed using a physical model, and, the
kind of shot the tennis players has to perform
for the resulting ball trajectory to look
believable.
This physical model even contains the ball’s
spin velocity, and the Magnus effect created
by this spin.
The entire chain of animations has to be correct,
and that’s exactly what happens here.
Bravo!
With blue, we can also specify the position
the player has to await in to hit the ball
next.
And these virtual characters don’t just
look like their real counterparts, they also
play like them.
You see, the authors analyzed the playstyle
of these athletes and built a heatmap that
contains information about their usual shot
placements for the forehand and backhand shots
separately, the average velocities of these
shots, and even their favored recovery positions.
If you have a closer look at the paper, you
will see that they not only include this kind
of statistical knowledge into their system,
but they really went the extra mile and included
common tennis strategies as well.
So, how does it work?
Let’s look under the hood.
First, it looks at broadcast footage, from
which, annotated clips are extracted that
contain the movement of these players.
If you look carefully, you see this red line
on the spine of the player, and some more,
these are annotations that tell the AI about
the pose of the players.
It builds a database from these clips and
chooses the appropriate piece of footage for
the action that is about to happen, which
sounds great in theory, but in a moment, you
will see that this is not nearly enough to
produce a believable animation.
For instance, we also need a rendering step,
which has to adjust this footage to the appropriate
perspective as you see here.
But we have to do way more to make this work.
Look!
Without additional considerations, we get
something like this.
Not good.
So, what happened here?
Well, given the fact that the source datasets
contain matches that are several hours long,
they therefore contain many different lighting
conditions.
With this, visual glitches are practically
guaranteed to happen.
To address this, the paper describes a normalization
step that can even these changes out.
How well does this do its job?
Let’s have a look.
This is the unnormalized case.
This short sequence appears to contain at
least 4 of these glitches, all of which are
quite apparent.
And now, let’s see the new system after
the normalization step.
Yup.
That’s what I am talking about!
But these are not the only considerations
the authors had to take to produce these amazing
results.
You see, oftentimes, quite a bit of information
is missing from these frames.
Our seasoned Fellow Scholars know not to despair,
because we can reach out to image inpainting
methods to address this.
These can fill in missing details in images
with sensible information.
You can see NVIDIA’s work from two years
ago that could do this reliably for a great
variety of images.
This new work uses a learning-based technique
called image to image translation to fill
in these details.
Of course, the advantages of this new system
are visible right away, and so are its limitations.
For instance, temporal coherence could be
improved, meaning that the tennis rackets
can appear or disappear from one frame to
another.
The sprites are not as detailed as they could
be, but, none of this really matters.
What matters is that now, what’s been previously
impossible is now possible, and two more papers
down the line, it is very likely that all
of these issues will be
ironed out.
What
a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!